especially for White's light squared  Bishop clear targets there I guess he  just had to fight on Dart squares this  is his idea as well he's going active  he's starting to set threats uh the  White's Rook is attacked by a Black's  Bishop and yeah black had to put one  Pawn on a dark Square because  potentially he was weak on that color  complex The Rook moves and the bishop  offers an exchange this is clever  if you remove white slight squared  Bishop which has happened oh there's a  blunder oh I was gonna say strategically  black was doing well but this Knight  drops off Black's Pawn is overworked if  black captures this Rook the White Queen  goes and captures the black Rook white  has one a piece  oh no and he resigns it's over John  Christoph Duda wins aim chess rapid  after a massive tournament he won the  preliminaries he knocked out Magnus  Carlsen in the semi-finals and he wins a  fantastically entertaining final against  chakrian mamadiara